really that what's really happening I'm
finally the you guys are getting an
exclusive here okay I preached all this
stuff that I'm showing them that I'm
doing now I was doing when I was making
those Muslims yeah you know all honest
now I just hit it I just hit it hit it
hit it hit it hit it yeah and I made
myself look like a saint
yeah and I made myself look like a saint
a saint the saint the saint and I would
never let them see me like it was I
actively made sure don't let anybody see
a picture of me Adam Smith hamdulillah
assalamualaikum greetings of peace
welcome to the Deen show which is a way
of life we try to put out there for
everyone to see helping you understand
Islam and Muslims we got a lot to talk
about
I made a promise I made a promise to
many people who are at the massacre that
we're going to answer your questions
and we're going to inshallah do that on
this week's episode of the D show we
also got a reaction video we're gonna do
with my next guest don't go anywhere
[Music]
people think that I'm ain't change and
that's why I am here it's really that
what's really happening I'm finally that
you guys are getting an exclusive here
okay I preached all this stuff that I'm
showing them that I'm doing now I was
doing when I was making those Muslims
yeah yeah I drank yeah I smoked
yeah I did all of that yeah you know we
all honest now I just hit it I just hit
it hit it hit it hit it hit it yeah and
I made myself look like a saint
yeah and I made myself look like a saint
the Saint the Saint the Saint and I
would never let them see me like it was
I actively made sure don't let anybody
see a picture of me out of club or with
a girl or drinking or smoking network's
reputation returning I had a whole past
I have a crazy I hid that yeah now at 26
I'm showing people you know what
I drank yeah I smoked yeah yeah I curse
I do this I do that so to them it's like
who is this guy yeah yeah yeah god this
guy is like he's changed things that
they think it's like once he hit X
amount of subscribers now he's off the
deep within really happening as though
I'm living in a more authentic version
of myself so I have to seeing that what
what is your I mean we're creatures of
imitation right it seems like Allah the
creator of the heavens and earth he had
programmed in us this this desire to to
want to imitate right and that's why
obviously he sent the messengers and but
many a time our youth and even adults we
get attached to certain figures and the
person will have maybe what's considered
the young Muslim name and do something
for Islam and you fish feel empowered so
you start watching them you connect with
them but then you hear this what are you
thoughts I'm smelly so so I'll solo
begin the name of Allah and mace finest
peace and blessings be upon His
Messenger Muhammad SAW mama holiday was
in them there's a lot to to gather from
a video like that but there's nothing
atypical about this we can never
underestimate the power of culture on us
and the fact that this is authentically
me as he puts it
in a sense I would have to agree with
him that if this is what he grew up
doing if this is what he grew up seeing
and then started doing he can be no
other person it's not authentically me
like he actively chose to be that person
that hides what they're more comfortable
doing because at the end of the day
we're all products of our environments
were so impressionable so he absorbed
all of this from the dominant culture
and then he hid it until it was
convenient to broadcast it in other
words it was more convenient to be
socially Muslim within a certain sphere
most likely is what he went through as
so many of us go through on one level or
another and then it could become more
appealing or more convenient to become
extremely controversial and puncture you
know wider spheres and wider audiences
all of us are going to be far more a
product of our circumstances our time
our age our culture than we'll ever
realize and so in a sense that is
authentically him meaning this is who he
truly is inside because this affected
him by osmosis by just absorption of his
surroundings more than what he was being
told and your cultural identity if it's
being inculcate it in you with greater
force with greater consistency than your
religious identity then that is more
likely who you're going to be right but
at the same time he may not realize that
it's not really authentically him
meaning he didn't in a vacuum choose to
be that party life personality that he's
saying he always was he's just following
the herd effect the rest of his culture
that's a glamourizing carnival izing
this world which is just a carnival as
Allah puts it it's all play and it's you
didn't choose this because you thought
it out or saw the perks in it you're
just doing what everybody else is doing
that's expected but at the same time
it's unfortunate
so also why Islam tells you to keep good
company right because it will absorb the
good out of the good mm-hmm
people I mean that's that's one of the
things you know that's that's wonderful
about this Deen that we have a creator
who's the most merciful
that that door of repentance is always
Ben and we have nothing but you know
love for people out there that's why we
we talk about these things to show
people that that there is a better way
you know what I mean because the things
that you do in this life it doesn't just
stop here it's gonna carry on you know
you plant seeds of goodness right you're
gonna end up benefiting right from that
but it also an another angle it's like
you know just to also help people not to
be so naive sometimes you know and
people go away from following the best
of mankind right to human being
deficient human beings that make
mistakes they get out there and they
might do something good right for Islam
and they might you know bring light to a
certain issue a topic but then what's
your measuring stick that's the thing
like how do we motivate people to know
like okay I can go so far with this
individual but I can never go too far
with following the Prophet SAW so much
right you know I mean to get people more
attached to following the Prophet
Mohammed peace that must has be upon him
just like you would follow Jesus during
his time Moses during his time and not
someone who had at the end you're duped
right I got you that what's really
happening I'm finally that you guys are
getting an exclusive here okay I push
all this stuff that I'm showing them
that I'm doing now I was doing when I
was making those Muslim video yeah and
that's what pretty much you know we
rocked it reacting to this video the
brothers like I got you I just hit it I
just hit it hit it hit it hit it hit it
yeah and I made myself look like a saint
yeah you know dari you thought it was
like the person was was hiding that they
were drink they were trying to pretend
like they were like you know this ideal
Muslim but we didn't expose them the
person exposed themselves but like they
took off you know that the sheep's
clothing you know the the Sheep the wolf
in sheep's clothing yes precisely
I would I mean I don't know what you
think but that's what it seems like the
the sheep's clothing came off says I got
you you've been duped certainly
certainly I mean so many of the figures
we grew up watching even non-muslims did
Jim Carrey's and and otherwise who made
us laugh and made us feel so good
momentarily how many of them you know
when the lights turned off and the
cameras shut down they were living the
most miserable lives some of them
committed
that filled our lives with laughs and
they filled their their private hours
with tears and Agony's and anxieties I
remember Jim Carrey in particular he
said I wish that everybody would make it
big make it to Hollywood and make tons
of money and drink and go to tons of
parties and drink tons of wine to
realize that this is not what you think
I heard that yeah and so there's a very
cool little phrase that I've identified
with a lot in my life and it helps me
from feeling too betrayed sometimes
feeling too frustrated sometimes holding
too many grudges sometimes and that is
that expectations meaning faulty
unrealistic expectations are the mother
of all frustrations you have this image
in your head that no one is gonna live
up to right of the perfect human being
except the human being whom allah azza
wajal chose instead this is your example
you'll never go wrong following him or
keeping him as your gold standard our
Prophet Muhammad Ali is all those to
them what advice would you give him and
shelah this comes to him what would you
what would the advice to soften his
heart or maybe to have him more reflect
upon these actions I don't want to say
I've been there I've been there before
Islam say you've been there yeah you
know what I'm saying things that we've
done that we're not you know proud of
but now we are where we are today before
Islam we tasted the dunya we left it
it's nothing there is sweetness of me I
am confident enough relatively if I've
relatively been there I can say I can
say with full confidence you're not
happy you're not settled
you're still Restless you're still
looking for something you're not quite
sure what you're looking for what you're
looking for is serenity because there's
a void inside you that nothing can fill
but allah subhanho wa taala
there's a need inside you that nothing
can satisfy with Allah there's a station
that nothing will fit correctly in but
it was what that station was corrected
created for and that is the adoring the
Lord of the world Subhanahu WA Ta'ala
devoting your life to him and every
single person even if they may put a
front or may respond just without
considering what I'm saying not knowing
that they're just in denial in a quiet
hour
alone with themselves maybe if Allah
sends them the gift of desperation as
they say something comes shattering down
in their lives and they just they have a
moment of pause they may remember these
words insha Allah and Allah may open
that window for them to consider and
reflect on it and realize yeah man like
why am i selling myself a lie and then
getting upset when I when I believed it
and it came back to haunt me and so when
allah subhanho wa taala says in the
quran i have not created humans or the
jinn except to devote their lives to me
this is not as society may put it forth
as some belligerent God just you know
unleashing a list of rules on you you
were great to do nothing but this Allah
is telling you how you function you will
not function well you will be
dysfunctional if you serve a purpose
other than the one for which you were
created we may need to clarify to them
as well they may have an understanding
that oh so I'm just going to sit there
and pray and fast and just like do
rituals all day I would say no no no but
consolidate your worries consolidate
your concerns consolidate your pursuits
and ambitions devote your life to a
meaning no matter what you do you don't
have to be a weirdo in life right but
let everything in life be about
something bigger than you and bigger
than life so that nothing down here can
really hold you down anymore because yes
you're living through life you're going
through the motions you're doing what
you need to do but you're you're longing
is for the heavens and so nothing can
break you nothing can disappoint you
because you haven't arrived yet right so
long as you're alive here and for many
people this has been their calling why
thinking this yeah I was made for this
nothing is gonna fit in the socket with
this right that would be a bit of where
I would start some maybe I would ask
them why they drifted away from
authentic Islam into what they now
consider authentic them yeah because
there are reasons for this sometimes
there are traumatic experiences or moral
conditioning or you know philosophical
bombardments and and so they get what I
would call over educated into thinking
that leaving this outdated backwards
lifestyle is the forward thinking
intellectual reasonable thing to do it
are someone sins ever that great
that Allah can't forgive them never that
allah subhanaw taala says no matter what
your sins are no matter what you've done
anything it's still a thing and Allah
summer see is wider than all things
that's a verse in the Quran he was mercy
expands wider than all things so what
would you recommend for let's say
someone made a mistake they were out
there you know and nowadays things reach
there all over the world and now someone
wants to turn back to the Creator how
can they make it right so if they're
remorseful and they're wondering should
I even is it even possible first of all
understand this is a an age-old trick of
Shaitaan
he makes like the the negligence or the
crime so tiny in your eyes badgering you
with whispers and so he said no big deal
everybody's doing it they didn't get hit
by no not lightning bolt just until you
actually do it right that sin is so
small fine we just do it then as soon as
you do it Shaitaan comes and plays
double agent and he says what he says
your sin is so big Allah will never
forgive it love mercy now is so small
and so no matter what you've done so
long as you're remorseful you're more
than halfway there and then we say that
Allah will never Commission you with
something beyond your capacity so your
obligation remains is limited to
expending you're all doing your due
diligence to make up for what has passed
within your capacity
if you cannot retrieve every last chair
and every last video and every last
recording has been reloaded on somebody
else's channel and things like this a
love will not squander your toe but
squander your repentance your redemption
because of something outside of your
grass or else none of the Companions of
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
who before they were companions killed
Muslims how did they become Muslim and
get forgiven for everything right like
they didn't give these companions whom
they martyred their lives back Allah
will give them the reward of martyrdom
and give you the reward of your
repentance mm-hmm because that's not
something difficult for him yeah no I
thought oh I mean that that is something
that is repeated often and over in the
Quran
of Allah the the reward of Jenna we know
this life is short we're gonna die I
mean people are dying every day and you
go to the graveyard and and it's not
restricted to just old people young
people middle-aged people every people
are just dying I mean that's what really
scared me into you know getting things
right is the reality of death you know I
mean getting myself together before that
moment comes
but now the consequence also we some
people often you know neglect you know
because we have constant you break the
laws of the land you you you know you
will suffer the consequences right but
how do we get people to to reflect upon
net that the same way man has laws the
Creator has laws and if you break those
laws there's consequences certainly I
mean I remember one time I was a good
brother of mine my partner in Darwin
we sat with a young lady and she said
she didn't believe in God and we went
through the motions as to how that's not
being very rational or scientific even
though you may presume so and so after a
while when she saw that it's undeniable
that God exists she said okay okay I'll
I'll admit it I just don't like religion
I don't like rules yeah
and so our brother he he went to a long
winded I guess technique of getting her
to consider I mean have some honest
shame here like when you came out of
your mom's stomach and it wasn't time to
drink and you wanted to drink you had to
follow the rules rules then you go to
like in the garden and and you wanna
double your recess duration but it's nap
time rules rules then you move on and
you want to like hang out with your
friends or watch another hour of movie
but it's like time for your SATs you're
gonna have to follow the rules and then
you you really want a rush to get to
this place because you were really late
and but there's a red light and gotta
follow the rules and then you get
married and you wanna eat out with your
friends but you know that if you don't
eat with the family it's gonna cause
some ruffling of feather so you follow
the rules and so we follow the rules for
our convenience this is actually for our
own well-being just weighing out the
pros and cons with everyone everything
and then when it comes to Allah who's
done more for us than anyone ever will
and will be with us at a time when no
one
when our lives are over and has more
ability and entitlement over us than
anyone ever has or will we want to be a
tough guy and say no I don't want to
follow his rules and feel like there's
gonna be no consequence doesn't make
sense at all yeah so tell us now we're
gonna get into some of these questions
you are and in in one of them you have a
dilemma that the person is going through
that they sign their kids up for a Hipps
program they really like the teacher but
they're teaching certain values to their
children at home
about not using certain words in
particular like dumb stupid and Cedric
Cedric but they're finding that their
teacher is getting very upset angry and
not controlling your temper and using
such words that they are telling their
kids not to use and when approaching the
teacher it's under this and maybe you
can define what this meter BIA write so
they're trying to understand like
because they we wouldn't tolerate this
in any secular school but why is this
happening right are we sending Mis mixed
signals to our children that there's a
lot of yeah yelling and shouting at the
kids what should i do should I take them
out they're scared that the children
might end up growing to resent current
to leave Islam maybe because it is
having a traumatizing experience how can
we address this with the teacher and and
what advice do you have for us okay
I pray Allah guides my words correctly
here irrespective of this particular
situation this could be something that's
like ubiquitous could be all across the
globe in many different spheres even in
the parenting dynamic with their
children and yes I mean you can
Institute right for Islamic research um
our inaugural research was the pathways
to doubt what causes people to doubt
what adds and there is no doubt that a
primary reason why people reconsider
their affiliation with Islam and start
doubting it is bad experiences that
cause a resentment whether it's
conscious or subconscious
of the religion and the personalities of
the religion and just the whole ethos I
don't want to be anywhere near that
atmosphere and so this is not a small
factor like I would so much rather
someone not be in tip-top shape as their
parents would want get to medical school
and memorize the whole Quran and because
that stress factor that the parents
sometimes artificially create it doesn't
have to be that way right kids have
different types of intelligence it
doesn't mean they're unintelligent if
they can't memorize Quran or if they
can't you know find a passion in
engineering or medicine or otherwise
there are different types of
intelligence there are different
interests in people at the end of the
day this stress causes parents and
educators terribly this means like
discipline or child rearing development
pedagogy it causes them to think that
there's a quick fix and that's what
makes them angry and the Prophet SAW
salam says does not get angry do not get
angry do not get angry and you know
Allah Bobby adore him unless something
very interesting when explaining this
hadith he says this like fundamental
advice should not be understood at face
value because anger is not a light
switch can't just not get angry so do
not become anger he says so it means
either number one because these are the
things within our capacity not only asks
us within our capacity means number one
don't put yourself in a situation where
you're gonna fall into anger right so
walk away from the conversation with
your spouse or stop having high
expectations of the person in front of
you impatience the things that make you
angry avoid them the precursors he says
number two or it means that when you get
angry don't act angry meaning restrain
your anger so part of restraining your
anger the problems also himself said
either Holly but looking for yes could
one of you becomes angry is not about to
speak because that only things things
works when you speak or act when you're
angry you will if you have some sort of
conscience regret it at some point later
oh man I broke the laptop oh snap I
divorced my wife I don't have anymore
divorce is despair oh man I pushed this
child away from the message it you know
they put on a show for me and they
memorize the entire Quran but they were
just using that as a reason to get out
of the program
they were accelerating they're jumping
ship from the Masjid atmosphere you will
regret it
that's a very important part what makes
us so impatient we think we have control
no you don't have control people have
their own pace that's a huge part of it
you know there's a very good book called
scream free parenting advice what does
it call scream free scream free
parenting you recommend that book
certainly and I haven't read it entirely
have to make it this but just the
concept of you actually being at the end
of your wits by screaming is what it
really boils down to like you feel like
I'm losing control no you were never in
control sometimes they just have to take
their natural course right the next
thing is this is a very forgotten Sunnah
of our prophet saww celebs to focus on
the positives this is what allows
negativity to evaporate right like we're
not even talking anymore about using bad
language that's unacceptable
unacceptable don't make dua against our
children we don't make dua against
people we don't use their argot Ori
language this is unbeaten of any
believer with adults with kids just is
there anything from the Quran and Sunnah
that somebody can use this as a form of
beer cuz most parents think okay maybe
this thing mom maybe he's got something
I don't know the whole Dean maybe
there's something there in the hadith
there's a wisdom behind this using such
words you know towards the kids is there
anything there a benefit and then people
will know specific like calling a kids
stupid [ __ ] absolutely fool we can say
that people will become agitated angry
emotional and that means that you're
like emotionally invested in the kid in
front of you that's fine right like I'm
gonna react sometimes because I care so
you're not so that's one thing though so
Quran Asuna nothing you cannot use Quran
and Sunnah to say that okay I'm
following Quran is to know what I mean
they gasp yes prophet a list of
ourselves faced and he said they said to
him mcdo against them he says my birth -
Lannon I did not I was not sent to
invoke God's curse perpetually
constantly on people he did in very rare
circumstances
her dad even says that David and Jesus
peace be upon them they made their
arrogance Benoa in Brawl salam in very
exceptional
exceptions he made do out this door out
to Allah right this is not lashing out
against people
these are against memories are trying to
kill you and even then he refused to be
recurrent with this he said I was not
sent to be like this but we're talking
about kids you're trying to teach the
Book of Allah the Quran you know it
reminds me of what when I think about
what is the Edison and Malik he served
the prophets awesome for how many years
10 years and what happened after you
forget cursing forget all he said he
never said to me about something I did
why did you do that or something I
didn't do why didn't you do that he said
I even tested him one time like I said
let me just see what he's gonna do when
I defy him and so he said to me to do
something and I am I refused so he came
out after me I was just deliberately
just playing with the boys in the
streets basically he came and he put his
hands on my shoulders gently i laced
about two of saddam and he said Oh
Anna's why don't you go do such-and-such
like you and I know you're suppose but
just look at the approach like human
beings are like seatbelts they just
don't come with snatching it just
doesn't work you know I'll give a
personal story just to show that I'm not
innocent I was so frustrated with one of
my children because they did not like to
be told what to do mmm-hmm and this
insha'Allah will be a good quality of
theirs if we're able to channel it
correctly that they will not buckle to
pressure they ever need to say a word of
truth speak truth to power and sha Allah
hopefully but I spent two years trying
to force my kid to say thank you and
just because I said what do we say say
thank you they would refuse to it's just
like I don't take orders mm-hmm and I
would get me so frustrated I was at the
end of my wits as they say and then my
wife said to me i'ma just ignore him
just praise his sister she's she'll
never forget to say thank after one week
mashallah so it's always says Thank You
Masha Allah you never forget to say
thank you this is all conversations
there in the back seat where in the
front seat usually within one week he
was saying thank yous without missing a
beat so the concept of positive
reinforcement catching people doing it
right and amplifying it that for their
sake and the sake of those around them
is so much more effective and so
much more merciful than focusing like
we're good at catching people doing
wrong things you know the Prophet SAW
said lumps he said to us that the
believers like a be right and I just
gave a whole but recently it's on
YouTube somewhere about are you a bee or
are you a fly this flies land on don't
yeah yeah number two or things that are
rotting carcasses and you know the
decomposing bodies of hundreds right
dirty things trash and bees land on the
nectar and they take the good from it
and they give the good back and they
land ever so gently and this was the
problems all I'm saying and so he used
to always land on the good things that
people are doing and praise them and
this has to be understood like the
concept of you shouldn't praise because
someone's gonna get deluded and
conceited the prophets are thought and
praised many people and so those a
hadith about don't praise must be
understood to mean don't excessively
praise don't praise when you feel like
someone's heads getting really big don't
praise in a way that's going to cause
them to become hearty and you know
pompous and proud and arrogant and the
likes but positive reinforcement it'll
make you happier like I was like my
goodness I put myself through two years
of stress about this issue and I was
almost about to give up and then Allah
blessed me with a with a wife who turned
on the lights for me and I was able like
my goodness it didn't have to be this
hard
yeah and so feeling you're in control
makes you too angry no it has to take
its natural course and not all kids are
the same pace now all kids are identical
even between boys and girls
I don't want against the gender debates
but boys and girls have general
tendencies that they are two camps right
so not the same exact form of Education
could necessarily be ideal for both
genders and appreciating that and
addressing it adequately will make
things so much more pleasant in the
educational atmospheres anyway I'm
ranting I'm so sorry no no so it takes a
little more effort here but you have
better results and it goes back here I
mean we've all been there I mean you and
I know I know personally you know you
get let's say you have you know six
seven eight nine kids you know you're
dealing with and you kind of lose your
cool and you you raise your voice and
and I take it from my own experience
after you you you go on a screaming rant
you know what I mean it just takes a lot
of energy out of you I've cut myself I
so is it really your order to do it the
other way no it's just harder to break
the habit break the harder to change
your lens from instead of noticing the
negative and only landing on that the
nasty stuff like the fly you just start
looking for the nectar and start landing
on that stuff your body is releasing
toxins actually when you get all
stressed out like that that are actually
cancer-causing toxic usually hot the
whole and in the end then it makes it
and I catch myself and I said okay I get
there's got to be a more efficient way I
understand sometimes you have to be firm
and whatnot but then going down to
demoralizing words I mean this is
something that obviously this is totally
sometimes you know there's needed so
this is a huge problem in in just
parenting apprehension yeah here's a tip
do not speak about people speak about
their actions golden rule do not speak
about people speak about their many at
times a parent or just a mentor or a
teacher they'll say you're dumb you're
hard-headed they may have been
unacceptable before of course
unacceptable we covered that okay I just
want to re-emphasize absolutely okay you
don't call a kid dumb you don't call
okay
I teach also I teach you know Marsha I
mean if I did that in one of my students
I'd be out of business customers I use
customers so we need to keep our
customers not from the financial
perspective from the Dean do you know
pure Research Forum says that the number
of people entering Islam are offsetting
the number of people leave leaving Islam
so it's just like no retaining your
capital is a far wiser economics wise
far wiser is the prudent thing to do
even if you're not gonna get any profits
right but really there's nothing
happening here
we're losing as many Muslims at least
according to those theories or those
those numbers as we are gaining yeah
that's just devastating they're both at
around 23 percent and so no absolutely
not so again do not write the child off
by branding them early right
the child is as
for being crafted and shaped as you're
willing to believe that they are the
prophet salaallah alayhi wasalam would
land on the good things and say to his
grandson or about his grandson he is a
saith he's a chief that's gonna lead the
people he would say that more either
Najib but who was 18 years old he's the
most knowledgeable of my own man
certainly they had they've done so many
studies on this man there's so much
research on this on this empowerment
yeah just even a touch right the reason
a person is more willing to do things
feels more motivated with a soft touch
with a soft word you know as opposed to
saying that's it this person is stubborn
okay might as well bring that I'm
stubborn yeah I'm sorry no that's all so
just the issue of mercy all right being
merciful with the creation is a
requirement for being eligible for the
mercy of God the Prophet SAW Salim said
that but he specifically mentioned after
that and alongside that that extra mercy
particular it's just so needed extra
mercy with the youngsters he says you
are not one of us they are not one of us
those who are not revering of our elders
merciful their youngsters and
recognizing the rights of our scholars
so this issue of I don't care how
religious you are I don't care how good
of a job you think you're doing I don't
care too much how sincere you are III
admire you sincerity but that is not
going to absolve us of using the wrong
techniques mercy is the most fundamental
technique you know the Prophet SAW said
another hadith
Allah is gentle and loves gentleness and
grants like there's good turnaround on
this stuff he grants on the basis of
gentleness what he does not grant on the
basis of harshness and we see that in
living color just try it you'll make
your life better and the life of those
that inshallah are trying to impact with
positive change better yeah just a few
more points and we'll conclude the
policeman is held to a higher standard
he's a police officer he has some ethics
he's got to go by the same way the mayor
the governor the president write Quran
teacher man this person is helping to
you know develop the future generations
let's say the person is teaching Quran
and the hold the Prophet Osama had said
it reminds me
that I have not been sent except to
perfect good manners certainly absolute
so now are you held to a higher standard
in a high Documenta element Khurana so
the best of you are those who teach the
Quran now if you're calling kids stupid
and foolish and you know demoralizing
them and then bringing them down and not
lifting them up and you're not and
you're not holding yourself to yourself
to the higher standard you're gonna be
accountable in front of a law right
absolutely not not to absolve anyone of
accountability we all have to answer for
our own but the poor and teacher should
be the last person to forget that right
that this is not about knowledge at the
end of the day this is not about us not
to recognize in the station of someone
who bears the sacred revelation but that
in and of itself will not qualify unless
it's matched with actions or it will
qualify to the degree that it matches
with your actions if you're calling to
Allah book with your words and deterring
from it or calling away from it with
your actions actions are gonna speak
louder than words so you're gonna have a
negative sum total at the end right Ana
may Allah protect us from from keeping
people from being able to get to him
right like may Allah protect this time
from us it's just it's a frightening but
a very real sentiment that we need to
remind each other yeah a couple more
things I can in mind is that I mean we
often talk about okay Shaitaan
facilitating away let's say on one end
right to the club's to the you know the
the sins of the desires and you know
negligence of performing and living your
purpose in life and etc etc right keeps
you there but then you come in you're in
the deen now you think okay you're safe
no you can go to extreme on some ends
and then also now say I thought doesn't
care which way you go he does long as
you're not here so now let's say even
here we're always being we're always
being attacked so it's a test of an
innocent slams a path ya deed yeah that
was not an act and you're training
you're teaching people about the book of
the Creator and your and their
responsibilities in life and to be
carriers preservers of this thing now
also is a positive Shaitaan can also be
you know trying to disrupt this because
now and get people out of programs like
this and because
these are future leaders I yet to forget
advice of one of my dear Mushaf and
mentors in Medina dr. sensual who said
to me once you need to realize that
Shaitaan is gonna work far harder on you
then he's gonna work on someone else
because everyone who considers you some
sort of inspiration or icon for guidance
or whatever it may be when you fall
people follow by example by association
just were followers by nature right if
you fall people fall with you whereas
another person if Shaitaan is able to
get them to fall they fall on their own
it's not consequential beyond their own
predicament and so we should certainly
be conscious of this more than others
right even span alone you imagine that
false sense of security that the
previous nations had that we read about
so much in the Quran it says and they
never became divisive and fell apart and
fragmented Elam in Bangladesh in Belgium
ain't home except after the knowledge
came to them due to animosity that
tensions arose after knowledge was there
you think knowledge is gonna solve it
but and knowledge will solve it sacred
revelation is the greatest gift Allah
sends to humanity greater than given
them their lives showing them how to
live and how to qualify for the next
life but the problem is our settling for
knowledge becomes the greatest detriment
to us because number one it will not
deliver us on its own and number two
those of knowledge when they fall all
those they carry fall with them yeah
someone says look brother you don't
understand these kids they act like you
know they're out of control and this how
we did it in my country brother you
don't understand it's not right what can
I say the gold standard is the Prophet
SAW Allah Allah Allah like are you doing
it right or was he doing it right I just
with all due respect the preservation of
our religion and the messenger of God
and the messenger of this religion has
to be preserved above preserving
personality so doesn't matter how we did
it in our country no it doesn't matter
so we did it in any time or any place
yeah unless it's conforming with the way
of the Prophet Valley so all those set
up we're not saying there can't be
different techniques for the
from times and places yeah like in
Africa if you're sitting in a tent
learning Quran from a slate that you're
carving in I would accept that that's
not necessarily contrary to the way of
the Prophet SAW said no it's not we're
talking about you right no one's saying
here we don't like about the schooling
system at there they took the desks out
and they want to do it the Africa no
that's not the way because that's just
about resources and technique and
whatever is available and readily
offered to the kids and that's not
contrary to Deen
we're talking about the aspects which
the Deen did regulate for our own
betterment those cannot be downplayed
mm-hmm one practical thing I think of
cos often you're going let's say you go
into an institution and you have like 30
40 kids the one teacher I mean I mean
that one thing you can do is like I
would think like because also were human
beings we're susceptible to losing
patients and whatnot maybe narrow it
down make less students you know to me
maybe focus on five ten get another
teacher for the rest because have you
ever walked into let's say a program you
got like 40 kids you're losing your mind
you know what I'm saying
what do you think some practical we can
do we gave the the the advice about the
book we took it back to Quran and Sunnah
it's not something that's allowed there
you actually do it more harm what are
the practical things tangible I mean
there are no reasons to invent to
reinvent the wheel as they say you know
there are people that are doing it right
to vortical law in different places
around the world in the United States
even if doing it right were employing
the rule of relativity here they're
doing a better job we can benefit
ourselves by just giving ourselves pause
to figure out what's the most efficient
way to do it yeah many times people are
know what's wrong with their methods
whether it's harm students of like
logistics or just conduct and but they
just don't know any other way and so I
think having that graciousness in us as
parents as Guster to offer them
alternatives like we're all in it
together like we all just want to make
the best out of a difficult situation
sometimes and so just suggesting
alternatives helping them develop a
reward system for example it's easy
right figuring out a way to be cost
efficient so you can hire an assistant
they just need help in that regard
someone who specialized in Quran doesn't
necessarily mean or usually many-a-times
does not mean that they're specialized
in administrative protocol and business
management and you know the five-year
plan any truth to this statement there's
no bad students only bad teachers have
you ever heard the statement it needs to
be qualified needs to be qualified it is
correct in the sense that you've heard
it you've heard this you're the teacher
yeah you're on the steering wheel you
can affect them in a way you're the
adult you're the parent yeah you can
affect them in more ways than you
realize
meaning 99% of the time there's
potential for high there's potential for
good you just need to be sure of that
and act on it the right way you got to
find it yeah so it's 99% of the time
it's there it's challenging at time
everyone's unique in their own normal
way we're learning on the job and none
of us are infallible and we're all
struggling and at the end of the day our
greatest asset is admitting our
powerlessness to Allah so Jen tell me a
lot I can't do it alone please open my
eye offer me the help I'm stranded
without you I mean I'm the first one
that could benefit from this I'm also
I'm trying to be a better parent I make
the mistakes I lose my cool hair ties
yeah but I'm trying to I try to I want
to be better I want to learn I want to
grow and inshallah if all of us can keep
that open mind and that's art this is
other the love the love it's not like
we're sitting here we say hey we figured
it out and we were perfect but all of us
are the slaves of Allah we make mistakes
but day's a night but Allah is most
merciful but we're trying to do these
things and benefit from these advice so
we can become better and shall a better
parents better worshipers of the Creator
and we can end up in Jenna but you know
what this is an excuse now to have you
back because we only did one question
and we got some more so the next time in
Chicago we gotta finish these is some
really good questions hopefully someone
better than me steps in it takes it I
enjoyed talking with you
inshaallah we can have a pleasure always
a pleasure thank you so much as not go
ahead can we do a shout out to our
cameraman hamza yes I love bless him
Eddie sons do an awesome job Michelle
he's an inspiration I'll raise his rank
and help us and him be carriers of his
book and his Dean I mean I mean where
can people get in contact with you they
can visit you at a website I'd rather
refer them to an Institute for Institute
it's doing amazing work inspiring
conviction contribution through
conviction check them out in child law I
have some work on there as well but stay
tuned for more and more hate from them
in Charlotte we're learning in a lot the
first part we talked about phousi you
don't want to be a fouseytube Muslim or
modified Muslim you want to be a Muslim
one who has submitted themselves to the
crater that has an earth Allah and we
talked about we're creatures of
imitation so out of his love Allah sent
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him to be imitated to be followed
his Sunnah we have it and you got a lot
of sensational people out there doing
some wonderful work maybe we can learn
some good things from him but you also
got some people who are doing opposite
to the true purpose of life we don't
want to follow them so the door of Allah
is love is always to his forgiveness is
open for fuzzy for juicy for all these
people and we got nothing but love for
him but we don't like the things that
many of these people are calling to it's
just like someone let me put it in a
more palatable way that you can
understand imagine you're in school and
you're being tested and for sure we're
being tested in this life and now you
got someone cutting class partying
flunking out failing and you got your
other friends saying come on man
let's go let's listen to the teacher
let's pass the class and let's graduate
with honors you ain't say nothing wrong
with that right and then you could be
successful well that's exactly what we
need to do in this life we're not an
accident that happened just randomly
appeared in this world no Allah created
us and he's testing us so when you pass
the test you got Jenna fail the test is
the consequence of hellfire and we don't
want to end up there so hopefully people
get this message they can go ahead and
if they're following people like that
they can waken it up and then we talked
about also recapping in summer
rising as I said before the policeman
has the responsibility he's held at a
higher level he's supposed to stop crime
not facilitate crime the same way the
Koran teacher as the prophecy Osama said
hi document elemental coronal mm the
best of you are those who learned the
Quran in teaching they had a higher
level the Quran teaches what patience
what does the Quran teach good manners
ethics along the foundation of
worshipping to create another the
creation pure monotheism so the Quran
teacher not just helping people memorize
the Quran but they have to be walking
the Quran with their good attitude good
manners good behavior so now if we're
teaching our kids not to use
demoralizing words stupid idiot [ __ ]
all these things and the Quran teachers
using it unacceptable unacceptable no we
wouldn't tolerate it in a regular school
of public school no way are we gonna
tolerate it from our current teachers
these are supposed to be the best
amongst us and insha'Allah they can get
this message with that love and we can
make these adjustments and they can
learn from it grow form because we're
human beings as a prophet saw some said
all of the sons of Adam are sinners
right but the best of those are those
who turn to Allah and repent and we're
all trying to grow we have to keep our
minds open learn grow and correct our
shortcomings and mistakes so we can
become better so we can get to Jenna
subscribe if you haven't already
hope you've benefited because we do this
out of the love we serve we sincerely
try thank you very much until next time
peace be with you
Salaam alaikum